your best friend is no you know we're
not making millions like that I can't
keep giving you money there's no
this is the reunion where we sit down
with former Collegiate athletes to
discuss life Sports and money
[Music]
I'm Taylor Brooks very happy to be
sitting down with Jason Collins and
Sylvia Fells so much to discuss but I
want to begin at the heart of it we were
I say we my twin brother we were five
three in the third grade we were taller
than our third grade teacher and our
parents were constantly looking to put
us into sports and something just
clicked with basketball we did have that
that love that passion for it and just
wanting to get better and better I went
to a basketball camp in the summer
and a player was talking about getting a
free education that was like okay
we're going to focus on basketball we're
going to give all the other sports up in
hopes to get a division one scholarship
because there was no way that our
parents were going to be able to afford
to put us both through college I grew up
in a single mom home and she raised five
kids I remember I just
joined eighth grade basketball team that
was my first time ever been on somebody
basketball team well you know I have to
say the fact that Sylvia in eighth grade
that was the first time on a real
basketball team and she became silly
us I mean I feel like that's kind of
late to be one of the greatest battles
yeah yeah well you know a lot of that
have to be blanked on my brothers
because I wasn't very educated on what
basketball was and when I played with
them they only made me play deep and so
I really didn't like the sport
so yeah
like I didn't understand I was like this
sporting dumb and then when I went out
and tried my eighth grade I was like oh
they've been playing me I was kind of
raw and green
um my go-to was just outrun everybody
and make layups um that's all I did
things like rebound run faster than
everybody make the left I want to say
probably about 10th grade where
everything click was like oh you can go
to college you know it's a possibility
you can make money you can like go for
free and stuff like that I was like oh
okay maybe I do want to pay attention
more and get better because not
everybody have the opportunity to make
it to the pros an athlete means a lot
and money has to be involved in that
because we do take our bodies through a
lot
[Music]
did you think in this moment though that
you would become you know one of the
best players absolutely not
um I knew if I put in work that I can be
good but I wasn't sure of how good all
my potential either like I didn't know
how good I was in college I just knew I
worked hard and I listened and I wanted
to get better every year but it really
didn't sink in until like you go back
and watch stuff 15 years ago it's like
oh man I was killing in college right
yeah in that moment I didn't think I was
that good
so in a perfect world for you how do we
talk about money in college what's a
good way to tell students financial
literacy every single team should bring
someone in and whether it's someone from
the financial world or a booster or
someone who's done really well
financially to talk to the kids colleges
need to have that as well now
[Music]
it was the recruitment process like for
you we were recruited by every single
college and then plus our parents said
have the grades to go to wherever you
want to go to we want to stay close to
home we got to play in front of our
grandparents aunt's Uncle you know all
in the Bay Area when you were in school
when you were growing up who did you go
to to talk about money
I went to my aunt and my parents my
parents were always picking the brains
of other parents who were doing well but
when I first got drafted and one of the
assistant coaches pulled me aside and
said hey you know
do you have someone here in New Jersey
because you'd like to be able to you
know see the financial advisor I
understood the importance of like how to
save your money and stuff like that but
also right before I got drafted I had a
talk with my financial advisor that oh I
was going to sign with and we came up
with a plan of what my money was going
to look like it was also a teaching
point for my family as well because it
got to the point where I was making more
than my mom my uncles and my aunts and
so basically I had to be a teaching
point for all of us because we like we
never seen money like this before yeah
so like how do you invest what do you
invest in like how that money comes back
and make a proper income where you don't
have to touch your salary that didn't
have access to like my master account to
be able to spend and it's still that way
today like I get money monthly to be
able to spend so
I got the lesson very early you're like
oh I got to do no I'm doing the exact
same thing yeah really I am yeah
nobody's the best piece of advice that
you hold on to still
um your best friend is no
um and I'm such a giver and I'm such a
people pleaser so I like to see people
happy and I want them to have things
that they have
um but it took me until like my second
year of the league I'm like you know
we're not making meetings like that I
can't keep giving you money
um and so your best friend is no what is
the thing that you would say to men just
about what they can do to continue to
push women forward watch watch the sport
I think all of us
have been put in this situation because
somebody else extended an arm and you
know has sort of held the door open for
us so try to put yourself in a position
to do that for somebody else on the show
we talk a lot about Financial Freedom
but I think that the word Freedom can
have many different meanings and I'm
curious the type of Freedom you feel you
experienced when you did decide to come
out the stress of not having to hide who
I am I'm not having to
you know let it go it's like it's out
there like this is who I am and seeing
how the basketball World reacted and
accepted me for who I am
um it was incredible and it really was a
freeing liberating and I I tell that to
other closeted athletes is you won't
have that stress of is today going to be
the day that they figure out were some
of the fears that you had actually kind
of quelled by what actually happened
[Laughter]
um because some of the fears that I had
um
you know you I had a fear of rejection
obviously I think that's the biggest one
is will I be able to still play
basketball well friends family
co-workers still uh respect me and
accept me for who I am for all those
people who had any issues that's on that
being in the closet for so many years
and just you know you're watching and
observing so many things but then
finally to be out there and be like okay
I'm going to step up and beam up my you
know and then be amongst the people and
be in those spaces where I'm working
through basketball or just you know in
front of a university audience you name
it but as my authentic self and nail
polish and braids and it looks like
whatever like this is me and um and just
spreading that message that it's okay to
be yourself I remember when you were
named one of the most influential people
like I genuinely remember it like it was
yesterday do you remember where you were
when this happened and how it felt very
important
um
I thought it was a shift in sports in
general because it's a it's one thing
it's almost like taboo like nobody
really want to talk about it but you
kind of know what's going on and it also
was a proud moment too because we get a
variety of things when you're in sports
and you learn how to cope with things
that the normal World tend to not want
to cope with and so you learn how to
accept everybody as who they are and and
you love them for who they are and so
for me that was that was big because I
knew it was going to be a shift so with
being one of the best
what lessons have you had to learn about
letting go when it came to retirement
[Music]
I really didn't have that problem
because basketball wasn't a love sport
for me basketball was a way for me to
better my life and I knew that at an
early age let's talk you know post
playing life the interest that you all
have you are fascinated with death yes
what is it about death that you have
always been drawn to death has always
stuck with me because
always felt like it was a place that we
leave after this but at the same time
it's also humbling like it makes you
appreciate the moment where are we at in
the process of you officially becoming a
mortician I'm actually I'm working okay
yeah so I work at the funeral home four
days out of the week and I'm happy with
it and I enjoy it I love this like you
get time for another passion yes I do
yes and this is a passion that is rooted
in love yeah I like working in the
community I've gone to Brazil China
Angola
um to name a few and then obviously all
parts of the United States but I like
being there with our community and
corporate partners and trying to work on
different programs to you know have
social impact through sport what has
basketball meant to your life basketball
has taken me around the world
basketball has given me a free education
a lot of my friends and family are from
the World of Sports and and I have a
really cool connection with my twin
brother through basketball because we
were both able to make it to the pros
and live out our dreams gave me the
opportunity to travel around the world
meet new people try different things
that's out of my comfort zone and be
more social I enjoyed this yes thank you
all so much you were fantastic and this
was The Reunion
foreign
[Music]